what we're trying to do is it says
without finding a primitive so what does
that mean like that first part of
statement you know when we differentiate
a function you're finding a derivative
and you're using all of your calculus
stuff like you know bring the index out
the front you know divide multiplied by
the index all that kind of thing so
we're integrating we can do that by
finding a primitive which is some of
that stuff which you saw in the exam you
know it's like oh if I have if I have
for example the integral of X to the
power of five with respect to X then we
do all of this stuff reversing all of
the rules that we learned before so I
would increase the index and then I
would divide by that index then I add my
constant of integration okay so what
I've just found there is the primitive
function now what they're suggesting in
this question is hey can you find out
the values of these definite integrals
without going through that process is
there other knowledge you can use
without having to resort to all this
fancy calculus and all that kind of
things so let's have a go Adam well
let's just start at papi I said Part C
is on when I own and start with okay so
we're integrating from negative 1 to 1
and the function they are interested in
is X cubed okay now to have a go at this
you do need to remember some of the
properties of definite integrals which
I'll review for you in a second that's
the first piece of knowledge you'll need
in the back of your mind and the second
thing is it is immensely helpful with
virtually all of these to have a kind of
picture in your mind as well the
question doesn't ask you to draw this
but as you'll see in a second once you
draw it it's kind of like oh oh is that
what they mean and it kind of means you
don't have to remember a list of
arbitrary properties which can be quite
hard the visual itself tells you what's
going on
ok so here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna draw a really quick and dirty
sketch of this function in here X cubed
because that's the theme that I'm being
asked to have a look at in relation to
its area okay so I'm just gonna do this
underneath here wow that's a terribly
not straight line that's much better
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
draw a rough plot of this X cubed graph
it's going to look roughly like this not
my best work but I'm it's it's close
enough for me
be happy with and I need to think about
what the question asks me to focus on in
relation to this graph okay now remember
they're integrating from negative one to
one that's what those boundaries are
okay so what they're saying is for the x
value negative one and the x value one
we're looking at the area connected
between this graph and the x axis I know
it's the x axis because of this part
along the end of the integral here it
says DX which means hey compare this
graph to the x axis right so if I draw a
few lines here to help a cell switchover
color from negative 1 to 1 you can see
it encloses this area between the black
graph and the red x-axis and I'm going
to shade in the part that's relevant
let's choose a color like that might
make it a bit narrower so here is the
area from negative 1 I'm going from the
left to the right and then I go forward
all the way up until 1 ok so this is
what the integral is asking us to focus
on hey can you tell me something about
this area now
the tricky thing with integrals or I
would say tricky but also powerful is
that unlike in normal measurement where
we say our lengths and areas have to be
positive in integration we have these
things called signed areas signed as in
positive or negative which is to say
when you've got this area on the left
hand side I hope you notice that when
you compare that to the x-axis this area
is beneath the x-axis that's negative so
this area here is actually going to
count for a negative result over here
this area is positive because it's above
the axis so when I put these two
together there's going to be an addition
and a subtraction happening now
hopefully even though my graph is not
beautiful you can tell that because this
is a special kind of function the area
on the left this one here and the area
on the right they are actually the same
in size yeah exactly a B well done
they are going to be the same areas at
least in terms of this size so because
once positive ones negative it's like oh
yeah add add five take away five or add
four take away four and that's why
you're actually just going to get zero
so no fancy calculus required on there
so the way that we would say it is it's
exactly right well done are you reading
my mind this is an odd function there's
a rotational symmetry to this so you're
always going to get this result zero if
your boundaries are symmetrical so
before I do another example question I
just want you to have a look at the rest
of the questions that you can see in
part in number seven you've got ABCDE F
do you see any others that are going to
follow that same kind of pattern where
you've got an odd function so you've got
this kind of symmetry to it do you see
which other parts we just saw see which
other ones are going to be like that yes
C D a well done and F what fantastic now
this is um really interesting I'm going
to pull you up on this for a second so
how do we know that different functions
are odd well see one of the reasons why
we call it odd symmetry is because
execute Ivy's notionally that's okay
I'll help you out
right odd symmetry is partly named
because it comes from odd polynomials or
I should say polynomials which have an
odd power so you can see up here right
you've got X cubed here that X cubed
because it's an odd number it's gonna
have odd symmetry if you have a look at
Part D you'll notice you've got the same
I shouldn't go right over you've got the
same odd power there 25 X this is a bit
sneaky it's also got an odd power but
it's just kind of hiding right it's a 1
so that power there is also odd I can do
some you know sort of fancy proofs for
you to show you the mechanics underneath
this if you like but the most important
thing for you to get down for now and
I'll write this down for you is that
when you add odd functions together the
sum of odd functions
give you an odd function in total should
write the sum that would be more helpful
let me move this out so it's a little
bit neater because I don't have enough
space here so if you have a bunch of odd
functions and you add them together x
cubed x to power 5 X to the power of 7
um sine X is another one you're going to
get an odd function as a result so
that's how we know the part C and D are
odd sine X how do we know that that's
odd this is kind of relying like I said
before on a sense of the image in your
mind of what the graph looks like ok so
I wonder if you could draw again a quick
and dirty version of this graph I'm
gonna draw here sine x is going to look
something like this and be really really
shape and sort of take advantage of the
fact that I can duplicate ok so it's not
too bad ok so what you've got here you
can see there's that same symmetry there
so if we consider from they want 90
degrees so that's over here and also
negative 90 which is over here you can
see again if I shade this area here and
this one here are equal in size or equal
magnitude but ones negative ones
positive so yes they're odd because the
powers are odd now the last one there f
to be fair and you this is actually very
sneaky here we haven't really covered
that yes a B it is always if they've got
odd powers you will always get an odd
function with odd symmetry out of that
and actually I'd encourage you to go and
go into desmos where's my and gone here
it is go into desmos and just have a bit
of a fiddle like here's X cubed a much
better version than the one that I drew
before and you can see it's got this
symmetry to it but if you change that
power up there to any odd number that
you like we could make that 5 you could
even if you want to be really sneaky you
could put in negative numbers there so
long as they're odd and you'll still get
that odd symmetry so yes you're always
going to get that in fact that's why
they're called why it's called an odd
function sine X like we came back to you
we had a look at this
and then I said I already got ahead of
myself when you're having a look at Part
F this is really really sneaky so I want
you to look carefully at it okay focus
first on the numerator and then we'll
get to the denominator this function in
the numerator is it odd or even kind of
think about it well done it's odd okay
so I'm just going to write that up the
top this is an odd function now what
about the one in the denominator this
one that's not what I wanted to do what
about this guy here 1 plus x squared
that's an even function right now what
would that mean what would that result
give us well it just so it turns out
when you take an odd function and you
multiply it by an even function or
divided by an even function for that
matter what you get is odd and I'll show
you right now let's go over back to
desmos what my desmos has got a bit
funny there we go full screen there we
go so I think the function from memory
was X divided by 1 plus x squared so
let's go ahead and put that in x squared
ok now this this is a weird looking guy
isn't it ok so we haven't really looked
closely at how to graph functions like
that
is it a raised parabola well the
denominator 1 plus x squared is a raised
parabola but when you combine it with
this X divided by 1 plus x squared you
get this weird little beast here ok so
an odd function divided by an even
function is another odd function this is
this is kind of weird and crazy and to
prove it I'm actually what I will do is
after this so that you can speed it up
slow it down as you prefer I'll go ahead
and prove that the sum of odd functions
will give you an odd function and also
if you multiply or divide on an even
functions you can work out things about
whether the whole result like this x
over 1 plus x squared is odd or even in
this case as you can clearly see from
the image the blue graph there the
result you get is odd so therefore if
you go from negative 2 there's negative
2 there let me write on this ok negative
2 let's choose a helpful color there's
negative 2 over there and there's 2
so when you're doing when you're
comparing the areas from negative two to
two you're still going to have an area
over here that's the same in size as
this one over here but one is positive
one is negative I guess you could say
they cancel out yes exactly it's zero
again so in these cases what you're
taking advantage of is these properties
of definite integrals let's just get
that out of the way you don't have to
learn how to integrate x over one plus x
squared which is good because I actually
need some really fancy techniques from
extension to to be able to do that sir
hopefully that makes sense actually take
that back this one's easy it ends up
with a log so that's what I get for not
paying close attention to the functions
so anyhow there's the result let us know
if that's if you require any extra
clarification on that but hopefully that
takes you through most of seven well
maybe I will just quickly come back a
and B have a look at those look closely
at them again the whole point is that
you have this messy looking thing but if
you think carefully about what's being
asked of you
it ends up actually being
straightforward look closely for a
minute okay yes sure all right so you
mean wait hold on that x squared are you
talking about Part A in that one there's
a yeah okay great so you've got an x
squared there you have three x squared
so you're right you're like oh these are
not going to be just odd or just even
functions again unless I look more
closely Part B is a mixture of on or
even functions right so in this case
rather have a look yeah you got a little
closely but boundaries right so if a and
B you're integrating from one a it's
from 3 to 3 and then from B it's from 4
to 4 so in other words you're looking
for an area but you start somewhere and
then you end somewhere so can I call
your mind back I wonder if I have it in
this actual page I don't think I do let
me find the right one for you there it
is ok so do you remember when we did
this lesson and we were looking at the
fundamental theorem of calculus does
this ring a bell look at this curve
thinking about you know what the current
virus looked like okay perfect all right
now we said that looking at an integral
gives you the area under the curve right
and I said if you
work out the area under the curve you
can go back to the primitive function
and just compare your start point and
your end point
well the start point and the end point
are the same place right when you're
looking at those two questions you're
going from 3 3 or 4 to 4 so what's the
what's the total change that was that
let me go to that big table that we drew
here right and the meaning of the
integral is what's the net amount of
change you're like well I didn't change
at all because the place that I started
at the place that ended is exactly the
same so that's why you end up getting an
answer of 0 so this is a hilarious part
in the solutions to look out because
Parts A through F the answers are all 0
you're like a company might did that
much work to get 0 6 times so does that
make sense Abby you're happy with that